Nous allons lire les premiers paragraphes du chapitre 8,
les Christes, les médiateurs,
de la confession de foi.
Donc juste une introduction,
c'est quoi une confession de foi,
c'est quoi un crédo pour ceux qui nous joignent,
peut-être pour la première fois.
La confession de foi, elle a un but d'expliquer
ou d'enseigner de manière concise
ou de définir de manière concise
les principales vérités bibliques.
Donc surtout aujourd'hui, on verra l'importance
de ne pas avoir une idée flux des dieux
et particulièrement une idée flux du Christ.
Ce n'est pas une répétition automatique
d'une profession des fois qui sauvera personne.
Il ne suffit jamais de dire, je crois Dieu,
si les dieux qu'on croit, c'est plutôt un idole créé par nous-mêmes.
Il ne suffit pas de dire, je crois Christ,
si mon idée du Christ n'est pas l'idée biblique.
Si pour moi, un Christ est quelqu'un
qui est venu améliorer légèrement ma vie,
je n'ai pas connu les Christ sauveurs
selon la parole des dieux.
Les Christ qui sauvent,
c'est les Christ qui accomplissent une œuvre
très bien définie
et clairement révélée dans la parole des dieux.
Et donc, il y a plusieurs doctrines que la Bible nous révèle.
Elles sont toutes connectées à Christ,
à notre compréhension du Christ.
Mais l'objectif des dieux, lorsqu'il s'est révélé dans sa parole,
c'est de nous donner la capacité de lui connaître avec des précisions
afin d'avoir une relation authentique avec lui en les connaissant.
Et donc, les confessions des fois ont été des efforts qui ont été faits
au fur et à mesure au long de l'histoire
où des hérésies apparaissaient.
Donc, si on mettait en question l'inspiration ou l'autorité des Écritures,
les théologiens faisaient des efforts
pour résumer l'enseignement de la Bible en elle-même,
car la Bible étant l'autorité suprême,
c'est elle qui doit nous enseigner ces choses.
Donc, qu'est-ce que la Bible a à enseigner à propos d'elle-même ?
Et donc, la première doctrine qu'on a étudiée dans la confession de foi,
c'était la doctrine à propos des Écritures.
Ok ?
Ensuite, on a considéré la doctrine sur Dieu.
C'est la doctrine principale.
C'est les festants de toute la théologie.
Qu'est-ce que la Bible enseigne elle-même ?
Qu'est-ce que Dieu lui-même enseigne dans sa parole à propos de lui-même ?
Donc, qui est Dieu dans son être essentiel, dans ses attributs, etc.
Et donc, c'est de cette manière que les confessions sont plus ou moins ordonnées,
mais elles ont, ou elles servent, elles ne sont pas inspirées,
elles ne sont pas parfaites,
mais elles veulent présenter de manière concise
les principaux enseignements bibliques sur les doctrines principales
afin de nous protéger, de nous dérouter dans notre compréhension
de ces vérités principales qui concernent notre salut.
Nous ne pouvons pas nous défier à cet égard,
car toute imprécision peut nous amener directement à l'enfer.
L'importance des doctrines bibliques, clairement comprises
et bibliquement comprises,
est illustrée par exemple par un aviateur,
un conducteur d'avion, comme on dit en français,
qui va négliger par exemple les changements d'un degré dans sa bussole.
Les distances, ça va être complètement différent de là où il voulait arriver.
Et c'est la même chose par rapport à notre foi.
Donc, l'utilité des confessions, elles sont très importantes à cet égard,
car par exemple, pour chaque phrase dans un paragraphe,
on est « backed up », on est, comment on dit ça en français ?
« Côtoyer », on dit, « supporter ».
Allez, traducteur.
Oui, on est soutenu, on est corroboré par des dizaines de textes bibliques.
Et donc, même si ce n'est pas inspiré,
c'est clairement et évidemment fondé sur des passages bibliques.
C'est des savoirs à reconnaître que Dieu a dû l'Église dans toutes les générations,
avec des hommes, des dieux sous l'influence de Saint-Esprit,
pas pour être des écrivains des Écritures,
mais pour avoir les ailes de préserver les contenus des Écritures comme il faut.
La Bible, elle est la seule source de connaissance des dieux,
fiable, mais elle est aussi la source des hérésies,
mal interprétées, mal intentionnées.
Et donc, c'est important pour nous de faire usage des confessions des fois,
et les confessions des fois ont toujours béni l'histoire de l'Église,
non seulement des manières à protéger la vérité biblique,
mais aussi des manières à servir comme un moyen des catéchèses,
d'enseignement didatique, comme on est en train de faire.
Et on verra les profits de tout ça.
Mais aussi des dévotions, et ça, je pense qu'on devrait restaurer,
utiliser les confessions des fois pour guider nos dévotions bibliques en famille,
afin d'enrichir aussi notre relation avec Dieu.
Car l'objectif de toute révélation biblique,
c'est un Dieu qui se révèle,
non seulement pour qu'on puisse les connaître de manière impersonnelle
ou les contempler dès loin,
mais c'est un Dieu qui se révèle,
afin de restaurer en nous les désirs
et l'objectif central de notre existence.
Il nous a créés pour lui,
pour être son image,
et pas tout simplement son image dans la manière dont on va être similaire à lui,
mais surtout dans cette proximité des réflexions,
des contemplations, des réjouissances, des relations.
Et donc, Dieu nous a créés pour lui,
pour prendre plaisir en lui,
et toute vérité biblique doit aboutir dans la contemplation de la gloire de Dieu,
afin de nous conduire à l'adoration de Dieu.
Et donc, quand on pense à la doctrine de la christologie,
je pense que c'est toujours important de regarder à nouveau la forêt
avant de contempler l'arbre ou la plante,
et surtout quand il s'agit des Christes médiateurs.
Donc, je vous ai proposé
que l'ordre confessionnel,
ou l'ordre des doctrines dans la confession,
elles ont, de manière très intentionnelle,
un ordre, qu'on pourrait dire,
de nous remettre à notre place
par rapport à la place que Dieu doit avoir.
Donc, nous, étant corrompus, pécheurs,
on peut développer très vite
une attitude envers Dieu et envers la vie
qui nous met trop au centre,
qui nous met dans une position très élevée,
ou qui nous place dans une position de victimisation extrême.
Et donc, comment la théologie doit être étudiée ?
Toujours du haut vers les bas.
Nous rappelons que nous ne sommes qu'à la poussière,
qui a reçu de l'importance de la part de Dieu
par pure grâce.
Il nous a tirés de la poussière de la terre
et il nous a soufflés son esprit.
Il a fait de nous son image.
Donc, toute importance qu'on puisse avoir,
tout jugement qu'on puisse faire,
ça vient des dieux.
Et donc, étant poussière,
nous devons encore nous rappeler
notre rébellion envers Dieu
de manière volontaire,
en mépris de la position privilégiée
qu'il nous a donnée.
Mais on n'arrive qu'à comprendre
combien on mérite vraiment
la punition qu'on mérite,
sans victimisation,
quand on considère d'abord
qui Dieu est.
Car on contemple Dieu
en tant que sommet
des toutes puretés absolues,
un Dieu inaccessible
par sa beauté,
son excellence et sa nature divine.
Et voilà pourquoi,
dans l'abordage confessionnel,
on commence
de la part des dieux
avant de considérer nos avis.
ça veut, par exemple,
pour la première doctrine
qu'on a étudiée,
la doctrine à propos
des Écritures,
la révélation des dieux.
Pourquoi ?
Car si nous voulons commencer
par nous-mêmes,
on aime bien s'accrocher
à la fabrique d'idole
que nous sommes,
nos perceptions
à propos des dieux,
notre idée des dieux.
Et des fois,
on entend ça
de la part de personne.
Donc,
c'est prédicateur
en train de me présenter
un dieu
qui je trouve trop sévère
pour moi.
mon dieu
n'est pas comme ça.
Mon dieu n'est pas...
Vous comprenez ?
Et donc,
la réalité,
c'est que
c'est important pour nous
dès le point de départ
de nous dire
il vaut mieux
que Dieu lui-même
se présente à nous,
que lui-même
nous dise qu'il est,
se révèle à nous.
Donc,
la Bible nous dit
que Dieu s'est révélé.
Il s'est révélé
dans la nature,
mais même
en contemplant la nature,
nous manquons,
c'est une crise
qu'on appelle
une crise épistémologique,
la crise de la connaissance,
même si on arrive
à avoir des idées
correctes à propos
des dieux,
ça sera toujours limité
par rapport
aux attributs
infinis des dieux
dans chaque facette
et dans son ensemble,
mais nous n'aurons
jamais la certitude
que nos idées
à propos des dieux
sont les bonnes.
Vous comprenez ?
Comment connaître
et comment être sûr
que ce que nous connaissons
est correct,
est vrai ?
Et donc,
en tant que créature,
nous ne pouvons jamais
arriver à la connaissance
des dieux
assurée.
On a besoin forcément
que Dieu nous confirme
nos conclusions
à propos de lui-même.
Mais le problème,
c'est qu'en plus
de cette limitation
créature devant
les créateurs,
il y a la limitation
de la corruption
du péché.
Nous voulons,
et nous avons
cette tendance constante,
soit à supprimer
l'existence des dieux
à cause de nos péchés,
soit domestiquer Dieu,
réduire Dieu
à nos propres idées.
et à la racine
de cette imagination
des dieux
qu'on veut créer,
il y a la corruption
du cœur,
de la volonté humaine,
la fabrique
d'idole
que nous sommes.
Et donc,
on a compris
que si nous voulons
connaître
à propos des dieux,
on a besoin
que Dieu se révèle,
mais pourquoi
on n'a pas sauté
directement
à la doctrine
sur Dieu ?
Car,
c'est important
pour nous
de reconnaître
que le seul endroit
avec certitude
où la vérité
sur Dieu
peut être trouvée,
c'est la Bible.
Et donc là,
on a compris
l'importance,
l'ordre confessionnel,
de commencer
avec la révélation
et pas avec nous-mêmes.
Vous êtes avec moi ?
Ensuite,
on a considéré aussi
qui Dieu est.
Et là,
on a compris,
c'est important
de commencer par Dieu
avant de considérer
la création
de l'homme
à son image.
Car si on commence
avec la création
de l'homme
à son image
pour après
considérer Dieu,
on a la tendance
et la tentation
d'être déjà
dans l'arrogance.
Mais nous ne sommes
qu'une image
de qui ?
De Dieu.
Et là,
on contemple Dieu
en commençant
par cette place
très élevée
de Dieu
avant de venir
considérer
qui nous sommes.
Et donc,
en considérant
les œuvres de Dieu,
on a aussi
suivre cet ordre.
Dieu d'abord,
les créatures célestes
et l'homme,
ok ?
comme les sommets
de toute la création,
super,
mais tirés
de la poussière.
Et donc,
là-même,
on était dans la bonne
dynamique en train
de considérer
tous les privilèges
qui nous ont été
accordés par pure grâce.
Et ensuite,
on a passé
à considérer
dans l'ensemble
des œuvres
de Dieu,
les décrets
éternels de Dieu,
c'est-à-dire
nos histoires
sont importantes,
mais nous n'avons pas
les centres
de contrôle
de nos histoires.
Nous sommes responsables,
il y aura toujours
cette tension
entre souveraineté
des dieux
et intervention divine
dans l'histoire,
mais aucune pensée,
aucune santé,
aucun jour,
aucune nourriture
ne nous est accordée
qu'est par nos propres mérites.
Nous sommes constamment
dans la dépendance
d'un Dieu
qui non seulement
a créé l'univers,
mais il a rédigé
l'histoire,
il gouverne l'histoire
et il soutient même
l'histoire.
Il soutient nos vies
dans les détails
microcosmiques,
macrocosmiques
et la réalité,
c'est ces dieux
qui participent
à la gouvernance
de l'histoire
à tous égards
et donc même
notre perspective
des œuvres
des dieux,
c'est une perspective
qui a d'abord
Dieu à sa place
et nous
dans notre petite
participation.
Et nous pouvons dire
la même chose
des autres doctrines.
Mais,
remarquez bien,
en tout ça,
on a bien fait
de remarquer
que l'ordre
dans la confession
de chaque doctrine
qu'on a considérée
jusqu'ici,
priorise à chaque fois
Dieu d'abord
et ensuite
les implications
pour nous.
D'accord ?
Mais on pourrait
rajouter
une autre ordre
confessionnel
qui est encore
plus importante
et certainement
plus évidente.
Une ordre confessionnel
qui va suivre
même les paramètres
bibliques.
Et c'est notamment
cet ordre
christocentrique.
Donc,
quelque part,
la considération
de chacune
de ces doctrines
jusqu'à ce que
Christ rentre
en scène
pour nous maintenant,
la révélation
des dieux
envers nous,
les besoins
d'une révélation
à cause
de nos péchés,
d'une révélation
qui puisse nous donner
la capacité
de comprendre
encore mieux
Dieu,
les besoins
de la révélation
spéciale
de la parole
des dieux.
Donc,
quand on a parlé
de la première doctrine
des Écritures,
c'était une manière
des dieux
de nous préparer
déjà
pour considérer
qu'un jour,
la parole
sera faite
chère
et nous aurions
la révélation
pleine
des dieux
de manière
accessible
à l'homme
car Dieu
est venu
en forme
humaine.
Vous êtes avec moi ?
Et l'impossibilité
de connaître Dieu
par notre propre
imagination
à cause du péché,
ça commence
à faire progresser
en nous
un total
besoin
d'une révélation
divine
qui puisse
ne pas tout simplement
nous rappeler
qui Dieu est,
mais nous donner
des informations
non seulement
à propos des dieux
mais de comment
nous pouvons connaître
Dieu
de manière expérimentale.
Connaître Dieu
pour avoir
une relation
avec lui.
Donc,
quelque part,
on est en train
de progresser
dans la direction
de la nécessité
absolue
de la venue
du Fils des dieux,
du Christ.
C'est de cette manière
que la Bible
a été révélée pour nous.
Pourquoi ces rappels
par rapport
à la création ?
Pourquoi ces rappels
par rapport
aux besoins
d'une révélation
qui puissent nous rappeler
à propos de la création,
à propos de qui Dieu est,
etc.
C'est car
Dieu,
il est en train
de faire progresser
en nous
les besoins
ou la nécessité
du Christ.
Mais c'est intéressant
car cette progression
dans la révélation divine
pour qu'on puisse comprendre
les besoins
et la nécessité
du Christ,
elle est très généreuse
car on n'est pas
qui devant
les besoins absolus
d'un Christ,
mais nous sommes
dans
la didatique
divine
qui va
remplir
des détails
comment
les Christ
doivent venir,
quelle est l'œuvre
qu'il doit accomplir,
pourquoi doit-il
être Dieu
et homme
en tant
qu'un autre
médiateur.
Donc,
vous comprenez ?
Toute cette didatique,
elle vient
dans l'ordre confessionnel
avec ses liens.
Donc,
par exemple,
si on étudie
sur les dieux
trinitaires,
Dieu le Père,
Dieu le Fils
et Dieu le Saint-Esprit,
nous sommes en train
de contempler déjà
la personne du Fils
des dieux
qui va incarner,
mais ça nous montre
dans un premier moment
que c'est Dieu
qui habite
dans une lumière
inaccessible,
c'est Dieu
qui est pur,
sans,
éternel,
qui est l'autorité
suprême,
la source
de toute moralité,
un Dieu d'amour,
un Dieu bienheureux
et à chaque fois
qu'on contemple
plus Dieu
dans sa beauté
et dans sa gloire,
les plus de la réaction
immédiate
et inévitable
pour toutes les personnes
qui ont été exposées
à la réalité
du vrai Dieu,
c'est de reconnaître
notre misère,
notre indignité,
notre totale incapacité.
Et donc,
si le Saint-Esprit
nous aide à contempler
la vérité sur Dieu
dans la Bible,
il nous conduit
inévitablement
à un mixte
d'un désir inévitable,
comme si on avait
redécouvert
la source
de notre existence,
de notre joie,
les sommets
de toute expérience humaine,
la contemplation
et la relation
avec ces dieux
si glorieux,
la réjouissance
et son adoration,
mais en même temps,
ces ministères
du Saint-Esprit
qui nous révèlent
qui Dieu est,
à la une
ou au même instant,
nous révèlent
qui nous sommes.
Et en nous révélant
qui nous sommes
dans notre misère,
même étudier sur Dieu
nous conduit
à la nécessité
absolue
de celui
qui pourrait
nous mettre
en relation
avec lui.
Vous comprenez ?
Même en étudiant
sur Dieu,
donc l'une
des notions,
des catégories
les plus importantes,
fondationnelles
pour comprendre
notre total
besoin
du Seigneur Jésus,
c'est notamment
par la reconnaissance
de qui est Dieu.
Car même
notre notion
de l'enfer
dépend de la pureté
absolue de Dieu
et notre notion
de paradis
dépend de sa gloire
et en voyant
ces deux
destinations possibles,
nous nous retrouvons
complètement
condamnés.
Et donc,
à partir de là,
la révélation
du Dieu trinitaire,
elle est aussi
en train de nous préparer
pour les besoins
du Christ.
Mais elle est en train
de nous préparer aussi
pour l'économie
de la rédemption.
C'est-à-dire,
si nous n'avions pas
un Dieu trinitaire,
on n'allait pas avoir
la possibilité
de notre rédemption.
Car Dieu le Père
doit rester dans sa position
en tant que juge,
les Fils doivent venir
pour accomplir
l'œuvre de la rédemption
et les Saint-Esprits
viendront pour appliquer
une fois qu'il crie,
il reviendra au paradis.
Et donc,
même là,
on est déjà en train
de contempler des choses
qui nous préparent
pour comprendre
encore mieux
les crises
telles qu'il viendra.
Vous êtes avec moi ?
Un autre aspect intéressant,
c'est quand on passe
aux doctrines
sur la création
et donc la doctrine
quand on pense
au décret des dieux,
quand on arrive
au Nouveau Testament
comme les textes
qu'on vient de lire,
il va faire converger
en Christ
toutes les choses.
Donc,
Christ au centre
de l'histoire.
Christ étant
la cible centrale,
la plénitude des temps
ou l'accomplissement
des temps,
c'est la manière
dont Dieu
qui a décrété
toutes les choses,
conduit toute l'histoire
à faire converger
la gloire des dieux
révélée en Christ.
et donc,
quand on perçoit
la manière
dont Dieu nous a créés
à son image
et cette relation
et cette interaction
avec Dieu,
on est en train
de contempler,
par exemple,
la création,
quels sont les privilèges
qu'on a perdus ?
Quels sont les privilèges
qu'on a ratés ?
Les paradis perdus,
l'état original,
la béatitude parfaite
et là,
on a un désir grandissant
en contemplant la création
comme dans un serment
de Lloyd-Jones
qui disait
paradis perdu,
paradis récupéré.
et il montre
comment tous les efforts
de toutes les formes
sociétales
qu'on a développées
des gouvernances
des pays
dans l'histoire,
c'est presque un désir
de retourner
à un paradis
qu'on n'arrive jamais
à retrouver sur Terre
qui puisse s'approcher
de cette réalité.
Et donc là,
à nouveau,
on est devant
les besoins absolus
de quelqu'un
qui puisse nous conduire
à nouveau
à ce paradis.
Ok ?
Ensuite,
quand on pense
à la chute,
c'est la manière
la plus explicite
dont la Bible
nous montre
les besoins absolus
du Christ,
on n'est pas
qu'en train
de comprendre
une anthropologie
qui puisse expliquer
les plus grandes crises
qu'on vit aujourd'hui.
Les crises
des coupabilités morales,
les crises
d'insatisfaction,
d'insécurité,
les crises
d'identité,
tout cela
est expliqué
par l'explication
biblique
à propos
de la doctrine
du péché,
de la rébellion
contre Dieu.
Donc,
nous sommes arrivés
à la conviction
que nous sommes
complètement coupables,
dépravés
ou corrompus
dans toutes les aires
de nos vies
et depuis la racine
et nous sommes
totalement incapables
de nous sortir
de cette condition.
Et donc,
pour meilleure
que ce soit
la possible thérapie
qu'on puisse chercher
dans cette vie,
ce n'est qu'un palliatif
très superficiel,
c'est comme si on voulait
donner un petit sirop
pour la gorge
à quelqu'un
qui a un cancer
des poumons.
Donc,
la maladie
est loin d'être têtée.
Elle peut être repoussée
dans notre imagination
mais ça va revenir toujours.
Et les problèmes
de la coupabilité,
c'est les pires.
C'est celui
qui est insupprimable
et qui va se manifester
de plusieurs manières
dans nos vies.
Et donc,
l'intérêt
d'avoir révélé
cette condition
tragique
de l'être humain
qui nous aide
à mieux comprendre
nos échecs,
ce n'est pas
pour qu'on reste
dans la compréhension
de nos échecs.
Mais c'est pour qu'on puisse
comprendre exactement
où les remèdes
sera pourvus,
les besoins absolus
du Christ.
Vous comprenez ?
Donc,
en mettant Dieu
à sa place
et nous à notre place,
on se protège
de toute victimisation
et on comprend mieux
pourquoi les choses
sont comme elles sont.
Mais en ayant Christ
au centre
de toutes ces doctrines,
on est en train
de considérer
comment Dieu,
il est en train
de nous préparer
par la révélation
de chacune
de ces doctrines
à comprendre mieux
les Christ
et son arrivée.
Et donc,
notamment,
la dernière,
les dernières études
qu'on a faites,
c'était les chapitres 7,
où on a considéré
l'alliance des dieux
avec les êtres humains.
Et ça,
c'est,
je dirais,
si on est en train
de suivre bien
ces catégories basiques
sur lesquelles
on n'arrive pas
à comprendre
les besoins du Christ,
là,
on commence à comprendre
un peu mieux
non seulement les besoins,
mais de quelle manière
sa venue sera pourvue.
Comment il viendra ?
Ça nous donne tout l'espoir
car Dieu a révélé
dès le départ
que sa relation
avec les êtres humains
serait basée
sur un cadre d'alliance.
Un Dieu
qui ne veut pas
tout simplement révéler
qu'il prend au sérieux
les relations,
mais qui va
encadrer nos relations
sur ces bases
qu'on a pu identifier
des conditions,
des promesses,
des serments,
des sanctions,
des médiations
par une représentation
fédérale
et cela
depuis la création.
Donc,
lorsqu'Adam
est tombé
dans les péchés,
avant la chute,
il était en condition
de tenir
sa partie
du pacte,
de l'alliance.
mais il était
les représentants
de toute l'humanité
et lorsqu'il a échoué,
ça a affecté
la relation
entre Dieu
et la race humaine
car il était
notre représentant
pour toujours.
Donc,
nous vivons encore
les conséquences
aussi
de sa représentation
fédérale.
Mais,
les côtés positifs,
donc,
c'est déjà,
on a déjà traité tout ça,
je ne vais pas revenir,
mais même si c'était
les mieux d'entre nous,
car les mieux d'entre nous,
selon les choix
des dieux,
et Dieu,
c'est lui qui choisit
avec les meilleurs critères
et les critères plus justes,
c'est impossible
qu'on puisse considérer
qu'il y ait quelqu'un
meilleur qu'Adam
pour être à sa place,
car Dieu est juste
dans son choix
de l'avoir choisi
comme notre représentant.
Et la réalité,
c'est que,
dans cet échec
qui a vécu
la race humaine
en Adam,
on avait quand même
les bases
d'une alliance
des grâces
qui allaient suivre
ces pactes
qui avaient été échoués
de la part de l'homme,
afin que la rédemption
soit établie
sur une base
des relations similaires.
Donc,
Dieu,
tout de suite
après la chute,
a promis
que de la descendance
de la femme
viendrait un qui sera
celui qui allait
écraser la tête
du serpent
et donc qui allait
finir avec l'inimitié
entre Dieu
et l'homme
qui allait porter
la réconciliation.
C'est Dieu lui-même
qui pourvoit,
je vous rappelle,
l'expiation temporaire
pour illustrer déjà
cette expiation
qui en substitue
à la souffrance
à notre place.
C'est Dieu lui-même
qui va couvrir
Adam et Ève
non avec les feuilles
qu'ils ont causées
pour eux-mêmes
mais avec les peaux
d'animaux
pour commencer
la didatique
envers les crises
qui viendraient.
Donc,
depuis la chute,
Dieu établit
une nouvelle alliance,
cette alliance
des grâces.
Mais les cadres
d'alliances
nous enseignent
de manière très claire
de quelle manière
et nous enseignent
de manière progressive
les crises
devraient venir.
Il devrait
accomplir toute la loi.
Il devrait être
un être humain,
être né d'une femme.
Mais comme
tous les nés
des femmes
sont nés
en péché
et dans la corruption,
on ne pourrait plus
avoir aucun espoir
qu'un être humain
soit capable
de nous représenter
et d'accomplir
toute la loi.
donc c'était nécessaire
que celui
qui allait venir
pour voir notre justice
ne soit pas contaminé
par la condamnation
de péché
et que la race humaine
était condamnée
et donc il fallait
qu'il soit un extraterrestre,
qu'il vienne d'ailleurs.
Et donc,
il vient d'ailleurs
sans contamination.
La naissance virginale
est une nécessité absolue
à cet égard
car il ne peut pas
être contaminé
par les péchés
et voilà pourquoi
Christ,
il vient exactement
de cette manière
pour accomplir
toute la loi
de manière fédérale,
de manière à nous représenter,
de manière à nous substituer.
Il doit être,
on va dire,
d'une origine pas humaine
donc divine.
Il doit être
les médiateurs parfaits
entre Dieu et homme
donc Dieu et homme
en même temps.
Il doit être
véritablement homme
et voilà pourquoi
même dans cette manière
progressive
dont Dieu a établi
plusieurs alliances
dans l'Ancien Testament
et dont il a révélé
clairement que Christ,
il est le médiateur parfait
qui était toujours
mentionné
et typifié
par chacune
de ces alliances.
Tout cela
nous préparait aussi
pour considérer Christ
comme les centres
de toute révélation biblique.
Donc,
vous comprenez
l'importance
de contempler
la forêt
avant même
de considérer
la feuille
et de quelle manière
glorieuse
la sagesse de Dieu
nous a révélés
de manière très didatique
comme des enfants
dans une école élémentaire
exactement
notre besoin du Christ
dans toutes les facettes
et à partir de là
les mouvements
de la confession de foi
sera de nous concentrer
sur la gloire
de la révélation biblique
à propos du Christ,
l'incarnation
de fils des dieux,
la christologie
et ensuite
la confession de foi
va continuer
par la considération
de comment Christ
qui est le centre
va déclencher
par son œuvre parfaite
toutes ses autres
implications
envers notre salut
de quelle manière
le Saint-Esprit
par exemple
va opérer
ou produire
le salut
dans nos vies
comment l'Église
doit être organisée
à la lumière
de sa relation
avec Christ
au centre
quelle est la relation
entre l'Église
et l'État
ayant Christ
pour centre
vous comprenez
donc toutes les aires
de la vie
et toutes les doctrines
qui seront traitées
par la confession de foi
continueront
d'avoir Christ
comme orbite
tous ceux qui étaient
avant
préparés
pour la nécessité
et pour la compréhension
tous ceux qui viendraient
après
serra connectés
à cette œuvre parfaite
qu'il a fait pour nous
et donc il est
au centre
de la révélation
biblique
et donc
en ayant considéré
l'ordre confessionnel
nous allons
considérer
quelques motivations
ou quelques arguments
pour la pertinence
de cette doctrine
donc avant la prière
je vous ai évoqué
on a plein de passages
bibliques
qu'on pourrait lire
et j'ai mentionné
par exemple
l'Apocalypse 4 et 5
pour nous rappeler
que Christ
il n'est pas
tout simplement
au centre
de l'histoire
car l'évidence
elle est là
nos calendriers
sont là
pour reconnaître
cette réalité
mais
il est au centre
de l'univers
de l'objet suprême
de cette réjouissance
intratrinitaire
divine
la relation
entre les pères
et les fils
et particulièrement
les fils
incarnés
et ressuscités
et donc
il est au centre
de tous les cosmos
il n'y a aucun thème
qui soit considéré
comme plus important
j'aimerais qu'on lise
ensemble
1 Timothée
13 à 16
on n'a pas encore lu
les premiers paragraphes
donc on va lire
merci Loïc
quoique
!
on peut le faire
plus tard aussi
on le fera plus tard
1 Timothée 3
nous allons lire
du verset
14 à 16
plutôt
Paul
qui
qui a écrit
cette lettre
et qui donne
la motivation principale
d'écrire
cette lettre ici
donc il dit
bon là c'est très important
donc on se plaint beaucoup
des pasteurs
qui sont là
mais les pasteurs
ne sont pas forcément
les pasteurs
pointés par Dieu
et ce passage
est la preuve
car il vient de présenter
les qualifications
bibliques
pour les pasteurs
les qualifications
bibliques
pour les diacres
pour les leadership
de l'église
si vous voulez
et ensuite
il va donner
les raisons
pour avoir
fait cela
c'est à dire
l'église du Christ
comme dit pour Achille
souvent
à la manière du Christ
c'est pas à nous
de chercher
à réinventer
de quelle manière
l'église
pourrait être
gérée
nous sommes
des entendants
des majordomes
de l'église du Christ
et voici
les raisons
présentées
par
par l'apôtre Paul
car
verset 14
j'écris ces choses
avec l'espérance
d'aller bientôt
vers toi
mais si je tarde
tu sauras
comment il faut
se conduire
dans la maison
des dieux
qui est l'église
du dieu vivant
la colonne
et l'appui
de la vérité
donc on doit
s'arrêter déjà
donc il a rédigé
les lettres
qu'on connaît
comme les lettres
pastorales
c'est là
c'est la première
lettre à Timothée
et son objectif
est clair
il y a une urgence
mais il n'a pas
il n'a pas
à attendre
les moments
il aura l'opportunité
de visiter en personne
Timothée
mais il faut
que Timothée
comme conducteur
d'église
sache comment
procéder
dans
la maison
des dieux
et donc la maison
c'est un rappel
avec un langage
très à l'Ancien Testament
du zèle
des dieux
sur sa maison
Dieu a déterminé
que l'église
serait appelée
sa maison
il allait faire
habitation
et on voit
de manière très claire
dans l'Ancien Testament
que la présence
favorable des dieux
la présence
perceptible des dieux
la lumière des dieux
qui lui
sur l'église
elle est conditionnée
par la manière
exacte
dont Dieu
est adoré
ça fait partie
des deux premiers commandements
du décalogue
ok
non seulement
adorer les vrais dieux
mais adorer les vrais dieux
de la manière
que lui-même
va prescrire
et voilà pourquoi
il était tellement généreux
dans l'Ancien Testament
pour donner tous les détails
de la construction
du tabernacle
et sa présence
ne vient qu'honorer
la construction du tabernacle
lorsque le tabernacle
est fait
est confectionné
est construit
exactement
de la manière
dont il a prescrit
et pour plus
que dans les Nouveaux Testaments
les choses soient
infiniment plus
simplifiées
car tout ce qui était
typifié
ou tout ce qui était
en train de typifier
les crises
dans l'Ancien Testament
a déjà été accompli
une fois que Christ
est venu
ça reste quand même
même dans sa simplicité
des règles
claires
et évidentes
dans les Nouveaux Testaments
quels sont les éléments
dans le culte
qu'est-ce qu'on doit faire
est-ce qu'il y a
dans la Bible
des bases bibliques
pour avoir
la danse
ou les théâtres
pendant les cultes
ce sont des questions
qu'on doit se poser
comment un serment
doit être prêché
comment identifier
un pasteur
si nous attendons
réjouir de la présence
des dieux
dans sa maison
il faut qu'on soit
en train de bâtir
sa maison
de respecter
et pas créer
notre maison
à notre manière
en abusant
de la maison
des dieux
et donc ensuite
il dit
maison des dieux
donc c'est pour
nous donner
cette couche
des crantes
envers la maison
des dieux
qui est l'église
du dieu vivant
et donc là
c'est pour donner
la propriété
de l'église
à dieu
donc l'église
de dieu vivant
ce sont ceux
qui ont été appelés
en dehors
ecclésiens
ok
appelés en dehors
séparés
du monde
et séparés
pour dieu
et voilà pourquoi
l'église en soi
doit être caractérisée
par cette séparation
radicale
du monde
si on arrive
à l'église
et on a l'impression
qu'on est plutôt
dans les mondes encore
on n'est pas à l'église
vous comprenez
et donc l'église
elle est
c'est le séparé
des dieux
pour devenir
sa propriété exclusive
un peuple
sanctifié pour lui
mais lorsqu'elle dit
les dieux vivants
elle est en train
de parler
de quelque chose
qui va évoquer
cette manifestation
des jugements
des dieux
contre
l'irresponsabilité
ou contre
ceux qui méprisent
sa manifestation
donc les dieux vivants
c'est les dieux
bien présents
les dieux bien présents
avec son zèle
c'est un dieu
qui est vivant
envers les ailes
pour son église
ok
et donc les dieux vivants
c'est ces dieux actifs
ces dieux
qui est là
avec les ailes
sur son église
et donc pourquoi
dieu est si vivant
envers l'église
car l'église
elle est là
elle est la colonne
elle n'a plus la vérité
ok ici c'est l'image
du temple
colonne
appui
ok
et l'image du temple
a pour but
nous rappeler
que nous sommes
devant la maison
des dieux
et la maison
elle est soutenue
et elle est faite
en tant qu'elle est
soutenue
par la vérité
révélée des dieux
et elle est l'appui
ou les promoteurs
de cette vérité
donc c'est défendre
la vérité biblique
et proclamer
c'est l'essence d'être
de là où dieu habite
vous voyez
c'est par là
que dieu se manifeste
défendre la vérité
promouvoir la vérité
ok
et donc voilà pourquoi
les ailes des dieux
sont si grandes
à nouveau
car la moindre déviation
liée à la vérité biblique
peut nous envoyer
dans une destinée éternelle
très loin
de la présence des dieux
et donc dieu
la colonne
l'appui de la vérité
et sans contredit
les mystères
de la piété est grand
et c'est là
où nous sommes devant
les plus grands
de tous les mystères
vous voyez
c'est l'un des passages
qui nous donne
l'explication
de la raison d'être
de l'église
du zèle
qu'on doit avoir
à l'église
et de tous les arguments
qui ont été présentés
jusqu'ici
c'est qu'il y a à cœur
car c'est une progression
qui part dans la direction
du respect
envers ces mystères
c'est l'environnement
où ces mystères
sera présenté
comme la vérité principale
où nous attendons
que ces mystères
soient révélés
comme la vérité principale
c'est les mystères
où dieu
va manifester
être présent
en train d'habiter
dans ces temples
dans l'église
par la présence
de ces mystères révélés
qui est
l'écrit
lui-même
et voilà pourquoi
nous voyons
non seulement
Christ
comme les centres
de l'histoire
du cosmos
etc.
mais les centres
de la révélation divine
de la manifestation
des dieux
et donc
quels sont les mystères
les plus grands mystères
de tous les mystères
et lorsque la Bible
utilise ces termes
mystères
c'est très important
de nous rappeler
lorsque la Bible
elle parle
d'un mystère
elle n'est pas
en train de préserver
elle n'est plus
les mystères
ok
l'évocation
d'un mystère
c'est un mystère
qui a été révélé
bien sûr
que plusieurs aspects
vont rester toujours
mystérieux pour nous
car bien au-delà
de notre capacité
de toute compréhension
mais la réalité
c'est que
Dieu a révélé
ces mystères
qui est les plus grands
de tous
Dieu
les dieux créateurs
s'est fait chair
Dieu
les dieux
supratemporels
éternels
a vécu
dans les temps
Dieu
les dieux
qui est la source
l'origine
et les mainteneurs
de la vie
est mort à la croix
vous comprenez
ça c'est les plus grands
de tous les mystères
Dieu
les dieux
trois fois cent
est venu
secourir
les rebelles
ennemis
contre lui
et donc
les plus grands
les plus stupéfiants
les plus étonnants
de tous les mystères
il est trouvé ici
et sans contredit
les mystères
de la piété
est grand
piété pour évoquer
cette relation
avec Dieu
que nous attendons
d'avoir à l'église
et quel est
le mystère
Dieu a été
manifesté
en chair
justifié
par l'esprit
vu des anges
prêché aux gentils
cru dans les mondes
élevé
dans la gloire
tous ces éléments
composent
ce qui est
le centre
de la révélation divine
les mystères
et tous
sont clairement
liés
à la révélation
du Christ
incarné
et donc là
ça montre
déjà
la pertinence
biblique
pour nous
d'étudier
ces thèmes
ou cette doctrine
ou cette vérité
et je voulais
vous présenter
quelques raisons
ou quelques
facettes
de cette pertinence
pour étudier
ces thèmes
donc déjà
c'est un thème
des centralités
absolues
comme nous sommes
en train de dire
les plus merveilleux
de tous les mystères
c'est le centre
et le cœur
de toute la révélation
biblique
il n'est pas
le point de départ
comme on a vu
mais il est au centre
tout pointe envers lui
et tout reste centré
sur lui
il est au centre
de l'histoire
notre calendrier
est divisé par ça
et il est
central
à la religion
chrétienne
c'est à dire
toutes les autres religions
pour plus qu'elles aient
toutes
un personnage
ou une personnalité
principale
la religion
en soi
ne dépend pas
si tant
de sa personnalité
principale
c'est plutôt
ses enseignements
les contenus
ok
mais
pour le christianisme
c'est très important
pour nous
d'apprendre à reconnaître
c'est la seule religion
qui dépend totalement
complètement
absolument
des Christ
de la personne
du Christ
telle qu'est définie
par la Bible
car si le Christ
n'est pas le Christ
biblique
il n'a pas la capacité
de supporter
cette religion
c'est une religion
qui dépend
complètement
de sa figure
principale
du Christ
c'est une religion
relationnelle
où Dieu
se révèle
en tant qu'homme
et donc c'est vital
pour le christianisme
donc l'œuvre
et la personne
de Jésus
telle qu'est la Bible
présente
elle est vitale
et vitale même
dans notre profession
des fois
car
si
dans notre profession
des fois
Jésus
est quelque chose
des moins
ou quelque chose
des plus
qui est ce que la Bible
présente
on est anathème
selon l'apôtre Paul
si notre évangile
n'est pas un évangile
centré
sur l'œuvre
biblique du Christ
et sur l'identité
nous sommes
anathème
c'est une exhortation
des condamnations
la moindre déviation
donc il y a
plusieurs doctrines
dont certains aspects
et certaines facettes
nous pouvons avoir
certaines divergences
car les explications
bibliques
peuvent ne pas être
si conclusives
que ça
sur certains aspects
mais étant
la doctrine
principale
la Bible
elle est
généreusement
claire
énormément
précise
et définie
par rapport aux choses
qu'on doit croire
à propos du Christ
et si on ne croit pas
ces choses
nous ne sommes pas
sauvés
si dans notre profession
des fois
nous manquons
des précisions
dans la compréhension
essentielle
de qui est Christ
et quelle est son œuvre
et si nous manquons
d'affection
radicale
par rapport à lui
et là je dis
radicale
dans les sens
les plus fondamentaux
car on n'aura
jamais la capacité
de l'aimer
à l'auteur
de son amabilité
mais il faut
qu'il soit quand même
paqué
en vernis
dans notre vie
la religion
pour nous
n'est pas une ère
comme le travail
les dégrés
ou la famille
les Christ
il est au cœur
au centre
de notre profession
des fois
il est vital
donc il faut
que ça soit clair
il faut que ça soit précis
c'est la raison
d'être des évangiles
pourquoi avons-nous
quatre évangiles
donc ils sont très clairs
par rapport
à leur objectif
et Luc les fait
de manière très explicite
il dit à Théophile
qu'il a écrit
ces choses
afin
de les rendre
davantage rassurés
des choses
à propos du Christ
et de son œuvre
donc pour que nous croyons
que les Christ
est les fils des dieux
est les messies
c'est le même objectif
pour les quatre évangiles
Jean étant
dès le départ
les plus explicites
à cet égard
mais tous les autres
dans une progression
qui va prouver
le fait
que Christ
est les fils des dieux
et donc là
on voit
de manière très claire
pourquoi
les auteurs
des évangiles
et pourquoi Dieu
a inspiré
les auteurs des évangiles
à être si généreux
et si précis
par rapport aux faits
relationnés au Christ
depuis pour certains
les prophéties
de l'Ancien Testament
et pour d'autres
des évidences claires
des l'onctions
de Saint-Esprit sur lui
sa résurrection
et tous ces autres éléments
comme la naissance virginale
sans lesquels
Christ ne peut pas sauver
vous comprenez ?
Si nous sommes
tellement affaiblis
dans notre foi
que nous voulons
croire en Christ
dans les globales
dans les totales
mais la naissance virginale
pas si tant
la résurrection
je ne sais pas
on n'a pas la vision
du Christ qui sauve
on n'a pas la compréhension
et donc les quatre évangiles
ils ont pris de la peine
car dès le départ
on avait des positions
et des visions
quand Christ demande
aux disciples
qui le peuple dit
que je suis
il donne des très beaux avis
à propos du Christ
mais aucun capable
de sauver
donc il était
comme l'un des prophètes
peut-être que Jean-Baptiste
peut-être
Élie
Jérémie
peut-être
Élie plutôt
et quelle est la réponse
du Christ
et vous
qui vous dites
qui je suis
et la réponse
très concise des pierres
mais la bonne réponse
tu es les Christs
c'est-à-dire les Messies
les fils de Dieu
vivant
et toi
si mon fils est Jonas
car c'est ni chère
ni sain
qui te l'ont révélé
mais mon Père
qui est au ciel
et donc on voit
de manière très claire
que si nous n'avons pas
la bonne compréhension
du Christ
on n'a pas les Christs
qui sauvent
et l'objectif des évangiles
était clairement
de nous donner
une compréhension
salvatrice
du Seigneur Jésus
et donc
ce n'est pas suffisant
de dire
je crois en Christ
mais c'est qu'on croit
à propos du Christ
et en qui on croit
quand on dit croire
en Christ
la première lettre
de Pierre
elle a été
rédigée
de manière très claire
selon la lettre
elle-même
elle nous dit
contre une hérésie
qu'on connaît
comme les docétismes
certains qui appréciaient
énormément les Christs
mais qui pour eux
Christ n'avait
qu'une apparence
d'un corps humain
car dans les docétismes
il y a cette dichotomie
entre la matière
et les spirituels
la matière serait
moins importante
corrompue
et Christ
il avait qu'une apparence
encore
et elle a été
fermement combattue
par les apôtres
et quand on considère
aussi
l'histoire
de l'Église
on va voir
que
les thèmes centrales
qui ont occupé
les quatre premiers siècles
de l'Église
et une bataille
qui a perduré
jusqu'au huitième siècle
c'était notamment
tout à propos
de la Christologie
la doctrine
de la Trinité
et ensuite
l'union
hypostatique
du Christ
c'est-à-dire
quelle est la relation
entre sa nature humaine
sa nature divine
en défendant
dure peine
et avec précision
biblique
d'un côté
sa pleine
nature divine
et sa vraie
nature humaine
100% Dieu
100% homme
sans mixture
des natures
sans séparation
et quelque chose
qui bien sûr
va garder
ces aspects
mystérieux
pour nous
on n'est pas appelé
à tout comprendre
ou à tout expliquer
mais nous sommes appelés
à faire confiance
à ce que Dieu
a révélé avec clarté
dans sa parole
et ces vérités
sont clairement révélées
dans sa parole
et donc pour plus
qu'on soit
parfois humble
et réticent
envers
tous les aspects
mystérieux
profonds
et élevés
il faut qu'on se rappelle
que Dieu
nous a créés
pour l'adorer
et l'objet
d'adoration
suprême
pour nous
à travers
qui Dieu
s'est révèle
c'est
les fils
et les fils
à travers
cette œuvre
merveilleuse
à la croix
et donc c'est-à-dire
nous ne pouvons pas
nous empêcher
de nous plonger
sur cette doctrine
qui est
la plus définitive
définitive
de notre
identité
en tant que chrétien
ce qui représente
l'objet central
de notre
adoration
et donc
les simplismes
parfois
on fait la confusion
entre les simplismes
et la simplicité
l'humilité
nous appellent
à nous approcher
avec humilité
mais les simplismes
ça nous rend
beaucoup
vulnérables
aux hérésies
ça peut être
un signe
des paresses
spirituelles
des manques
de diligence
et des mépris
même
envers la révélation
divine
car si Christ
s'est révélé
de cette manière
si Dieu
nous a révélé
tellement de vérités
glorieuses
à propos du Christ
pour plus
qu'il s'appuie
sonner
comme au-delà
de nos capacités
Dieu
ne doute pas
de sa capacité
de se révéler
à nous
et il n'a pas
une vision
si baisse
de nous-mêmes
donc tous les chrétiens
ont la capacité
de suivre
les pistes bibliques
pour grandir
dans sa compréhension
pour dilater
son affection
pour s'approfondir
dans sa relation
avec un Christ
qui est mieux défini
par les paroles
de vie
bibliques
et donc là
on ne peut pas
tomber dans cette dynamique
et on voit comment
dans toute l'histoire
de l'Église
la réforme protestante
elle était surtout
une restauration
de ses confessions
ou de ses crédos
de ses symboles
des cinq premiers siècles
de l'Église
et aussi surtout
la question
de l'œuvre du Christ
on a eu aussi
plus récemment
dans l'ère
des théologies
thématiques
au 19e
18e siècle
avec les modernismes
les rationalismes
les développements
de la science
une nouvelle mise
en question
de certains faits
de l'Évangile
les faits surnaturels
on croyait
avec un naturalisme
exagéré
que Dieu ne pourrait
pas interférer
dans les naturels
que tout était réduit
à des relations
des causes
et effets
dans un système
fermé
des phénomènes
naturels
et à partir de là
nous avons vu
en fait
deux extrêmes
deux réactions
de l'Église
d'un côté
un mysticisme
désinformé
une espèce
de New Age
évangélique
qui perdure
jusqu'à aujourd'hui
dans certains cercles
très émotionnalistes
mais de l'autre côté
certains
qui ont voulu
s'ébattre
pour défendre
la vérité
par la théologie
systématique
aussi
et donc
c'était très important
de lutter
pour cette défense
et cette restauration
des faits
de l'Évangile
les faits
on vient de lire
les textes
ces mystères
qui ont été révélés
donc ça parle
du Saint-Esprit
qui est dans l'histoire
a versé son onction
envers les Christs
afin qu'ils soient
identifiés
et justifiés
comme fils des dieux
sur terre
par les miracles
qu'il a opérés
et qui ont
des enregistrements
historiques
fiables
et on voit
la même chose
par sa résurrection
d'entre les morts
il a été cru
dans les mondes
dans un monde
en opposition
en persécution
il y a plein
d'évidence
de la revendication
historique du Christ
et donc
si nous sommes
menacés
par les scientificismes
de nos jours
contre la naissance
virginale du Christ
ou la résurrection
du Christ
ou les miracles
nous devons rester
accrochés
aux évidences
bibliques
et même historiques
de ces réalités
et donc encore aujourd'hui
on a un scepticisme
à cet égard
mais nous devrons
nous rappeler
de l'importance
de toutes ces précisions
bibliques
à propos de la personne
et de l'œuvre
du Seigneur Jésus Christ
et donc pas
pas des excuses
pour nous
pour ne pas nous plonger
dans un thème
si glorieux
même si l'attitude
envers ces thèmes
doit être une attitude
de beaucoup d'humilité
et totale dépendance
de la révélation
biblique
mais c'est Dieu
à révéler
avec précision
avec clarté
lorsque les personnes
s'opposent à croire
c'est pas par manque
d'évidence
d'un mystère révélé
de la part des dieux
de manière si glorieuse
et si évidente
donc l'évangile
a été prêché
car Christ
selon les choix des dieux
a été exposé
comme crucifié
publiquement
devant tous les mondes
vous vous rappelez
de la crucifixion du Christ
et cela a été enregistré
dans la Bible
de manière préventive
ou de manière
comment dire
anticipée
par les prophéties
et cela a été
gravé
cela a été
enregistré
de manière définie
dans la Bible
pour toute l'histoire
donc notre histoire
est divisée
et marquée
par Christ au centre
c'est-à-dire
Dieu a été généreux
et précis
dans l'effet
de la révélation
du fils des dieux
en tant qu'homme
et sa crucifixion
à la croix
et sa résurrection
et Dieu a été généré
aussi dans l'explication
de ces faits
et ces implications
théologiques
pour nous
et les